And this one's a big one, okay?
Okay.
Okay, um...
um...
Did you love me?
Hi, I'm Paulo and I'm a director here at Jubilee.
As you all know,
we've been living in this global pandemic and
time of social isolation
and I've been sensing that people are feeling lonely
and longing for human connection.
More people have been calling their families and friends, doing group calls.
And it just made me realize that this is a perfect opportunity for people to reconnect.
And so we wanted to make a series where we challenge people to muster up the courage, get out of their comfort zones, and
call people they might have had a falling-out with.
I am calling an old friend.
Well, I'm calling my dad.
I'm calling...
my ex-boyfriend.
I'm about to call my dad.
Some reached out,
reconnected and took the leap.
When I was younger I actually moved to Alaska.
When I got there I was a loner,
I was the kid that no one really talked to, I was the loser, but not Kim.
She definitely was the one that spoke to me.
She accepted me for who I was.
I want to ask her if the reason why she stopped talking to me was because
she had a boyfriend.
I'm calling my dad.
I feel like he neglected me as a daughter. There were so many lies,
there is so much mistrust.
I really want to connect and understand if he still sees me as his daughter or
if he's still willing to see me in the future.
I guess you can say he was like my first love, you know.
Like, that somebody you're always gonna have the most feelings for.
The day that we kind of just ended it
was the day he told me that he was signing another six-year contract to go to Guam.
And he was like,
"I think we should just be friends." and that was like the last thing we said to each other. So...
I still want to express like the fact that I'm still like in love with him,
but it's also like we left off at like a weird spot.
My dad has been in and out of my life.
Around sixth grade I decided,  you know, not to have anything-
I didn't wanna have anything to do with him and you know, he reached out to me many times,
but I kept denying his effort.
Around this time last year,
I was in a fatal car accident and during rehab, I was isolated most of the time so I had a *lot* of
time and room for you know self-reflection and improvement and that's why I'm here today,
taking the leap.
Even last night knowing that I was gonna do this, I couldn't sleep.
I just... I... my mind is just racing. It's going a thousand miles an hour.
Hyshler: Heeeey!
Kim: It's been a while!
Hyshler:  It's been a while, it's so good to see you.
Kim: It's good to see you too. You look good!
Hyshler:  Thank you, you know working out little bit, just a little bit, not a lot.
I'm just very shaky,
I'm very scared.
I just expect that he's going to give me an apology.
Papa: Yes?
Kathylynn: Hi, Papa!
Papa: Hello
Kathylynn: What happened?
Papa: What do you mean "What happened"?
Kathylynn: What happened to your hair?
Papa: Oh, I just woke up.
I'm not ready.
Julia: Hello?
Gil: Hey, what's up?
Julia: Okay, so are you ready for this?
Gil: Uhh... yeah, why not
Julia: I'm gonna be asking you some questions,
because I want to like, it's like a whole thing where you can like reconnect with people.
And like, you were the person I wanted to reconnect with.
A lot of these questions are gonna be like about our relationship.
So yes, get ready.
Gil: I was born ready.
Julia: Yes, okay.
I'm about to take the leap.
Wish me luck.
Daja: Okay, again, thank you for being here.
Do I have permission to record.. to record this?
Dad: Yes, you sure do.
Hyshler:  When I first moved to Alaska, you were one of my first friends, and you made me feel
important, you made me feel loved, you made me feel welcomed and then there was this period of time.
Um... and still kind of current where we just don't talk
Kim: Yeah, there was a-
a sudden drop in communication from both of us.
Right around when I started... dating
Hyshler: That's actually, that's funny that you say that 'cause...
That's what I was gonna ask you.
like why did that happen? Like, why did you...
I guess cut off.. or not cut off our friendship, but,
why... yeah, I guess why did you cut it off, yeah?
Kim: Well
It wasn't intentional.
That relationship was not healthy.
Hyshler: I felt like...
Maybe it was me.
You know you got like the new shiny toy so you just like 'discard me.'
You know, like that's how I felt and you know, I- I just for a long time
I was really bitter.
Kim: You know that relationship- because that relationship is done.
Hyshler: Is done?
Kim: That's over. Yeah I got out of that
Hyshler: Oh my God.
Kim: Maybe we can text, y'know, and it can be like old times
Hyshler: Yes!
Kim: Which would be awesome,
Because, you know, non-stop laughter!
Hyshler: Yeah.
Kim: You know, I miss that. I do.
I know that I was a healthier person when I had that in my life.
Hyshler: Same, same.
Kim: So, I'm very happy that you reached out to me.
Hyshler: I hope that, you know, this is like the start of something new um...
Shout out to High School Musical.
And I will talk to you later.
Kim: Alright, you better!
Hyshler: Yes, I will.
Kathylynn: Like I know we haven't been talking for a while.
I just wanted to know if you like still like...
Like want to see me again?
Like in person.
Like you haven't seen us since-
Papa: You said ' I want to see you' right?
Yeah, you haven't seen us in a while. Like you haven't seen me since I was in middle school.
Papa: Okay, so do you want me to visit you or you want to visit me?
Kathylynn: I-I mean, how come you haven't visited us?
Papa: I can't,
Kathylynn: Why?
Papa: I don't know where you live.
Kathylynn: You never asked!
Papa: No, [I've] always asked your mom.
Kathylynn: You're the one who told me face to face that I am no longer your daughter.
And you tell that to Caitlyn too and I don't
understand why you would say that, and at the same time tell me that you still love me.
Like why would you say that you love me?
If you don't try to come see us and deny it right in front of the court.
Papa: Okay, what I did-
What I said to you before, 'I don't like you guys anymore'
But what you did to me.
You know, first
I have a big problem [with] you, what you did to me.
Kathylynn: What did I do? What did I do to you?
Papa: Okay, you did not respect me
Kathylynn: Have you thought about how you respected us?
Have you thought about how many lies you said about my mom?
Have you thought of that? Where's the respect in that?
How come you can't respect your own daughters?
Papa: Okay just- just stop this conversation, okay?
It's not gonna happen for that thing, okay?
We're not going to solve this problem, okay?
You're getting old soon, okay?
Just realize what your mom did to me.
Kathylynn: Okay, alright.
Okay, Papa, I'll catch you later.
Papa: Okay.
Kathylynn: Okay, bye.
Julia: Okay.
Umm...
Do you believe like the question "right person - wrong time"?
Gil: Yeah,
Definitely in a heartbeat, I would go back to it if I could,
But it wouldn't be the best decision
Or the healthiest decision, for either of us.
Julia: Yeah.
Gil: You want to up to school in New York and
I'm going to a different country.
Julia: This one's a big one, okay?
Okay, um..
um...
Did you love me?
Gil: Yes!
Julia: Okay.
Gil: I did.
Julia: I was thinking- like I was thinking about it and I remember it like.. the first time you said it your way.
And um... you called me,
and you were like...
Ooh, gosh, you were like, "I have something to tell you."
He was like "I hope you're sitting down right now."
Do you remember?
Gil: Yeah.
Julia: And you were like, "I'm about to knock your socks off," and I was like,
"Why? Like what are you gonna say to me right now?"
And you were like,
"I love you." And I was like "What?!"
Gil: Yeah.
Julia: Was it hard to end the relationship?
Gil: Was it hard to end it?
Gil: Yeah.
I still think about it a lot.
Gill: Alright.
Julia: Thank you.
Gil: You're very welcome, I'll be around tonight if you need me.
Julia: Okay, bye.
Oh my God...
Daja: Okay.
Again, thank you for being here.
The last time we met there were like 11-12 years of resentment and..
you know things that were unsaid?
Well, I was brutally honest and at the same time, I wasn't truthful...
and I was having trouble, you know,
facing the things that I can and can't change and one of those things is that... you are my dad.
Dad: You know, I had the same problems, like with my dad as well
And trying to learn how to love him and forgive him for not being a part of my life.
So I get it, and you're a lot like me.
I have a hard time verbalizing and saying how I honestly feel.
So, yeah, I get it.
Daja: I did this, came on here just to tell you that...
That I...
That I forgive you,
that I chose- and I choose you. And if you ever wondered...
that if I ever loved you... that-
that I forgive you... so..-
Dad: I appreciate you forgiving me, that means the world to me, to hear you say that.
Wow...
That was huge for you, huh?
Daja: Yeah. Yeah.
Dad: Are we going to meet once a month?
You know, you come here or I come there or
Are we going to talk or text frequently?
like, I don't know
I kind of need an after action plan.
Daja: Seeing each other once a month sounds...
Really good.
Again, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Dad: You're welcome, love you
Daja: I'm gonna end it now.
This... this was a lot for me in that moment.
In that moment, it was, you know, just a lot.
And now I'm just, you know, just letting-
just letting it go and...
I feel... lighter.
Which you know, I'm a heavy individual,
but I feel lighter.
He didn't answer my questions at all.
I'm just going to be happy for him.
That's... that's just it. I'm happy for him...
after everything.
I look like a mess.
There is so much closure... and I honestly...
If...
you need to call someone right now and tell them, "Hey,
I love you. Hey, I miss you.",
take this as an opportunity.
You never know unless you try.
I hope you enjoyed that episode.
I just want to say thank you to all the people who submitted videos, were brave and
willing to be vulnerable on camera.
Thank you so much.
And... if you're interested in maybe reaching out or reconnecting with
someone and taking the leap,
then click on the link in the description below
and maybe you can be featured in a future episode.
Thanks for watching and until next time.